hindsight is 20/20 and after going
through Fire Emblem three houses we
found even more things we wish we knew
before we started our tenure at Garrick
Mach monastery fair warning there are
some minor spoilers in this video but we
believe these tips are more useful
before you encounter them there are
loads of different support conversations
to be had between students and faculty
however it never gets to a point where
you can date any of them some ice rinks
have a suggestion of marriage but that's
as far as it ever goes students also
can't date each other so you can't be
playing matchmaker either fishing
doesn't cost any activity points and it
increases your professor level making it
a must for every Sunday you decide to
explore the monastery on some Sundays
they're rare fish that can be caught and
sold for lots of cash to have a better
chance of catching these fish we
actually recommend not always going for
the first fish that grabs your line when
a fish catches on you'll see an icon in
the bottom right telling you the rarity
of the fish you'll want to wait for the
purple gold or rainbow fish icon to
appear be careful though there's a risk
of losing your line after the third try
or fourth if you're lucky
[Music]
in the month of September flame will go
missing and your mission for the month
is to find her during your time
exploring the monastery that month you
could speak with your house leader to
trigger a quest that asked you to find
clues about flames whereabouts there is
a prime suspect however if you decide to
enter their room right away you will
automatically skip to the end of
September we recommend waiting until the
end of the month before you trigger that
quest so you continue to spend activity
points and cultivate your team
battalions are extremely useful for
almost every character in the game
they provide stat buffs and allow gambit
attacks the only character you should
avoid giving a battalion to is Felix
from the blue lions as it conflicts with
his unique ability battalions do cost
money to recruit and replenish Plus what
you can equip is limited by authority
skill and whether you have a flying unit
or not so keep that in mind when
deciding who should and shouldn't get
one special merchant vendors show up
after you clear certain battles once
they do arrive at Garrick Mach it's a
good idea to buy as many presents as you
can from them as they'll give more
motivation than ordinary presents
depending on who you give them to
sharing meals can cover a lot of your
students motivation already but as you
expand into recruiting more students and
characters this can become an effective
way to increase motivation and social
rank for more people in one day
each month you can have one student from
another house assist your team in
battles for that month this can be
extremely useful as you'll have one
extra person on the team and they can
help balance out a weak spot your team
might have this can also help build your
bonds with that character if you're
looking to potentially recruit them
however that character won't receive any
experience and you'll be taking away
experience you could be giving to one of
your own units
[Applause]
on top of lost items sometimes you'll
find guides for cooking or fishing just
lying around grabbing these will
increase your professor level at no cost
despite its ethical implications don't
be shy about entering the rooms of your
students and other professors in order
to grab some of these basically just
pick up any glowing blue object you see
on the ground and we suggest looking
around for more every time you enter a
new month occasionally you'll pick up
rusted weapons on the battlefield this
will happen more often if you're
connected online and land on squares
that are glowing purple don't
immediately throw them away however
instead you should inspect them with X
on the inventory screen to see if the
rusted weapon has the potential to
become a grater if you forge them with
the blacksmith well some could simply go
from rusted to iron others can be forged
into uniquely named weapons which are
super rare just a heads up the
blacksmith isn't available until a few
months in and you need to complete a
side quest to open it
didn't quite get all the characters up
to their highest support level or just
want to see how a different house
unfolds after you complete the game
there's a new game plus mode first of
all it doesn't wipe your main save data
so you're good after that you'll retain
shop levels and statue perks but you can
now spend renowned on a number of things
to put you back at the levels you were
at in your original file this includes
your professor level the skills of the
professor and the students and the
support levels between characters you
don't have all the renowned in the world
though so it's important to choose what
you want to regain faster
this one is more of a fun little easter
egg than it is a tip have you ever
noticed that the little sprite avatar on
the loading screen is moving well you
can actually control which direction
they move and how fast they're moving
it's all in the gyro controls so that
means tilting your controller or tilting
the system itself if you're in handheld
mode you can also hit B to jump and a to
flip their cape those are just a few
more things we wish we knew in Fire
Emblem three houses if you haven't seen
our first video about nine things we
wish we knew you should definitely give
it a watch anything you found that's
been helpful in your playthrough leave
it down in the comments and thanks for
watching
[Music]